all my vietnamese friends have never  gotten sick my whole life have you ever  seen a vietnamese man with a flu before  it's usually the vietnamese that are  mixed with chinese that got flus  that's me man me and all my homies we  went down to mexico to eat street tacos  we all had the shits except for the  vietnamese homie no but the thing is it  distributed and then the vietnamese guy  he didn't eat the bad one defenders saw  the viet guy and went hey you get this  one number three let your weird ass  friends eat the shitty stuff  you live the good life you're a chinese  friend little mom brother  doma brother he's like some kind of  sympathizer  it should have been you guys you guys  are one they're in mexico yeah yeah yeah  he's a huge history speaking english  what other asian countries is there  there's mongolia